До 150 тисяч гривень на відкриття власного бізнесу -
нещодавно влада виступила з черговою ініціативою щодо підтримки заробітчан, які повертаються в Україну.
Відповідний законопроєкт, розроблений урядом, вже передано у Верховну Раду.
В уряді впевнені: така допомога стане ефективним стимулом для повернення трудових мігрантів на батьківщину.
Ми розраховуємо, що така підтримка від держави дасть стимул для людей лишатися в Україні, відкривати малий або сімейний бізнес,
інвестувати кошти у свою громаду, у нові робочі місця - для українців, для членів своїх родин.
Це розумна політика, спрямована на те, аби українці розвивали власну економіку, власну країну, власні громади.
Щоправда, для отримання допомоги треба буде виконати низку мов. Зокрема, інвестувати таку ж саму суму власних коштів.
А також мати 10 років страхового стажу в Україні, адже гроші планують надавати з Фонду державного соціального страхування.
Якщо стажу бракує, допомогу згодом треба буде повернути. Утім, заробітчан, з якими поспілкувалась Deutsche Welle, відлякує не це.
Віталій Коваленко, який працює водієм автобуса у Словаччині та заробляє близько 850 євро на місяць, каже:
інвестувати у власний бізнес у розпал пандемії - занадто ризиковано.
Я вважаю, що це великий ризик. Бо що можна розвивати, коли все стоїть і всі сидять вдома без грошей?
Я просто не розумію, що можна розвивати. За кордоном, звичайно, впевненіше себе почуваєш, якщо маєш роботу і не захворієш.
Звичайно, люди захищені більше, оплачуються лікарняні і місце зберігається робоче, переживають за тебе.
Звичайно, хотілося б, щоб так і вдома було, але поки що це тільки мрії.
Так що, поки буде можливість тут знаходитися, будемо знаходитись тут.
Віталій поїхав у Словаччину влітку минулого року - у розпал пандемії коронавірусу.
Представники компаній з працевлаштування кажуть: влаштуватися на роботу за кордоном навіть попри локдаун - не проблема.
Стабільно є вакансії у харчовій промисловості, є багато вакансій на складах,
адже під час пандемії у Польщі дуже розвинулась онлайн-торгівля.
Деякі сфери економіки вже відкриваються, і ми всі з нетерпінням чекаємо, коли відкриються готелі і гастрономія.
Ходять чутки, що це станеться 14-го лютого. Дуже багато мігрантів з України працювало саме в цих галузях.
Тому коли почнуть відкриватися готелі та ресторани, а це швидше за все станеться найближчим часом,
з'являться нові вакансії, і буде дуже великий попит на працівників.
За словами Томаша Богдевича, за кордоном навіть на некваліфікованих роботах можна заробити до 900 євро на місяць.
Для більшості заробітчан, принаймні поки що, це більш приваблива перспектива,
ніж підприємництво в Україні - навіть попри урядову допомогу.
Кожна ініціатива, яка просуває бізнес, допомагає економіці - це добре.
Але треба дивитися на нюанси. Чи вплине вона якось на те, що трудові мігранти з Польщі та з інших країн повертатимуться в Україну?
Мені здається, ні. Адже, по-перше, не кожен хоче ставати підприємцем.
Крім того, люди розуміють, яка ситуація в Україні.
Відкривати там бізнес - це не до кінця стабільно, не до кінця зрозумілі умови.
Надання грошової допомоги на відкриття бізнесу - не перша ініціатива влади з реінтеграції заробітчан на межі популізму.
Ще навесні минулого року, після масового повернення трудових мігрантів,
створення мільйонів робочих місць для заробітчан анонсував президент Володимир Зеленський:
Зараз в Україну повернулися дуже багато громадян із-за кордону.
Це добра новина, хай і обставини такого повернення не найприємніші.
Але рано чи пізно коронавірус пройде і карантин закінчиться.
Вважаю, що ми повинні зробити все і втримати цих людей на батьківщині.
Нам дуже потрібні ваші знання і ваші вміння.
Тому пропоную уряду розробити додатковий механізм, який створить додаткові мільйони робочих місць.
Саме в цьому контексті знаковим є продовження програми "Велике будівництво" -
тисячі кілометрів нових доріг та інфраструктурні об'єкти
дадуть той необхідний імпульс економічного розвитку та створять нові робочі місця.
Щоправда, ідея подолати кризу на ринку праці завдяки будівництву,
яка показала себе ефективною майже 100 років тому у США часів Великої Депресії, в Україні 2020 року не спрацювала.
Не варто очікувати дива і від нинішньої ініціативи уряду надавати підтримку заробітчанам,
які бажають стати підприємцями, вважає експерт з економіки Павло Кухта.
Я не думаю, що це якось суттєво вплине на ситуацію. Не факт, що ми навіть побачимо ефект у статистиці.
Зберігається різниця в рівні можливостей заробити гроші, а також в якості життя, в якості сервісів - в усьому.
Відповідно буде постійно оцей перетік людей з більш бідної країни до більш заможної.
Єдиний спосіб це виправити - це провести реформи, зняти те, що заважає інвесторам прийти в Україну, залучити інвестиції,
і зачекати, поки цих робочих місць буде достатньо, будуть достатньо високі доходи, коли люди зможуть працювати тут так само,
як вони працюють на Заході. Іншого рецепту просто не існує в природі.
Загальний обсяг коштів, який уряд пропонує виділити заробітчанам, які бажають відкрити бізнес в Україні, - 108 мільйонів гривень на рік.
Тобто допомогу зможуть отримати лише близько 700 осіб.
Це - менше одного відсотка українців, які працюють за кордоном.
Тим часом, заробітчани і в часи пандемії залишаються надважливим елементом економіки України.
У 2020 році вони переказали на батьківщину рекордні 12 мільярдів доларів.